some say that defunding the police means
that people want to allocate some of the
police budget to other programs and
improve the community
others say it will cause issues with
crime what are your thoughts
um we've talked about this a bit yeah
it's a catastrophe and here's why
the the cops and the necessity to have
so many cops and to have them so
well armed all of that is a downstream
consequence of really crappy policy
designed to keep people in line after
you've frozen them out of
the well-being that they're entitled to
so
if you then reduce the
level of policing and you reallocate
you're not solving that
upstream problem and so you're going to
create a problem of not enough police
you're going after the symptom right
you're going after the symptom and
some people do say that that's what they
mean when they say defund the police and
some people do mean that but not all of
them mean that
and some of them are quite obvious in
what they're saying when they say i mean
you showed a new york times op-ed a week
or two ago saying yeah actually we do
mean abolish the police what we mean
about the place
so i mean the fact that there's this one
phrase that actually means two
very different things is part of the
problem i mean it's it's like calling
the whole movement anti-racist when it's
frankly
patently not and saying oh we only mean
this one thing well no actually some of
you mean
abolish the police entirely and that's a
non-starter
therefore you got to at least stop using
that phrase because
some people are using it to mean
something um impossible it would be the
equivalent
it's the equivalent of treating a fever
when the fever is actually your body's
way
of dealing with a pathogen so you've got
a pathogen you say oh
oh my god you've got a pathogen you've
got a fever the fever is bad
therefore get rid of the fever well now
you've got a worse problem with your
pathogen
right or treating pneumonia by denying
the patient
fluids right you're drowning your lungs
are filling with fluid let's let's
dehydrate you yeah we'll dry you right
up we'll dry you right out
okay it's just nonsense this is not
going to work so it's not
that people like us don't want to see
fewer police
we do but we want to see fewer police by
virtue of the fact that they're no
longer necessary by virtue of the fact
that you've solved the
upstream problem first it's the obvious
way to go
so that's that's excellent simple as
that that's good and i like
you know this this this fever point is
one that began to be being made in the
90s
with the as as darwinian medicine began
to gain ground and then kind of stalled
out
um but you know the recognition that
often a fever is the body's way
uh no the pa the body's response to the
pathogen
to raise the temperature in which the
pathogen exists outside of its optical
zone such the pathogen fails
but not so high that the body fails
that's not what all fevers are but that
turns out to be what many fevers are
but this the second one this uh well one
symptom of pneumonia is that you appear
to be drowning
let's dry them up i think actually
interjecting both these examples um
whenever
people say defund the police it's it is
it is the right analogy
knee-jerk medicine yeah knee-jerk yeah
and then this is knee jerk social change
defend the police knee jerk social
change we've got a whole epidemic of
knee-jerk medicine
your teeth are misaligned let's drag
them to the right place oh
that's a good idea what could go wrong
yes right the person's depressed ah
let's give them something to interfere
with the molecules that facilitate
depression
do they have anything to be depressed
about that's
that's a difficult question that's too
complicated settle on an easier question
yeah let's go after the molecules